[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning there's
been a huge spike in
internet scams targeting americans the
fbi says
2020 was a record year with almost 800
000
complaints this year investigators
expect around a million
the financial losses last year totaled
more than four billion dollars and the
scams
are getting much more sophisticated our
consumer investigative correspondent
anna werner visited
a small business in maine that was
targeted by fraudsters anna good morning
good morning anthony and this is a story
that these business owners wanted to
tell
to warn others because they say the
damage to small businesses can not only
hurt that business
but the employees who rely on it even
the local economy
on any lake in maine chances are you'll
see sam miriam's boat docks lining the
shore
a lot of docks there's a lot of docks
his company great northern docks custom
builds the platforms and
parts employing 20 people but he says
he came close to losing it all last
october when the company's accountant
went online to send out the weekly
payroll from
key bank it was like a bombshell it was
unthinkable what happened accountant
shelly brown says she'd just gotten a
new computer the day before
and in order to send out the payroll she
searched the internet for the bank's
payroll website called
key navigator and logged on was it
pretty much the first site that came up
yes you put in your same username
password
once on the site she says a message said
it was undergoing system maintenance
but then her phone rang showing key bank
on the caller id
telling me again that the system was
under maintenance and they should have
it fixed within a few hours
later that day she checked the site
again and got a second phone call
and they said well we're not going to be
able to get it done today
but you should be able to be up and
running by morning seems totally normal
yes but the next morning she had an
email from the bank
which said that we had overdrawn our
account
we never overdraw funds ever so i knew
something was up at that point
brown says she immediately logged onto
the bank's website from her home
computer
and saw withdrawal after withdrawal four
thousand
eighteen thousand fifty one thousand
dollars
when you realize that sick
sick to my stomach and then she had to
tell her boss
maryam and she said something's very
wrong i've got all these
transactions that have happened and i
can't explain them
68 transactions in all it just
felt devastating i don't know how else
to say it
249 thousand dollars gone
it was totally shocking shocking
and i think of sam as
a brother and his reason for wanting me
to be in the role i was in because he
could trust me
you feel like you let somebody down
that's my job
miriam's company fell victim to internet
scammers who the fbi
says are increasingly targeting american
businesses
cyber division unit chief donna gregory
on the business side
there's a lot more money it's a bigger
bang for the buck
you're going to get you know six figures
or more those scammers set up fraudulent
sites that can look identical to the
real ones
like the key bank site miriam's
bookkeeper logged onto
a cyber security firm he hired found it
was a fraudulent site that behaved
just like the genuine site and the
people who called her
the crooks themselves with a faked
caller id
that said key bank the criminals are
very good at this
they've actually really perfected this
over time
it's a business but merriam says he
didn't originally think he'd lose the
whole quarter of a million dollars
he says his contract with key bank
called for it not to allow
payouts greater than 25 thousand dollars
per week
but he says the bank later told him it
wasn't responsible
and i said so you're saying i'm on my
own
he said unfortunately yes key bank would
not comment on miriam's case
but it confirmed a trend of spoofed
websites and said
it is identified and helped to take down
approximately 150 of those fake sites
the bank says it takes steps to alert
clients so they can avoid becoming a
victim of fraud
and works directly with clients to
recover any losses that they can
but miriam and brown say in their case
the bank's security protocols
failed i feel that key bank really let
us down
you're mad i am mad i think the bank
should be protecting
us as customers consumers
and they didn't miriam says he was
fortunate enough to sustain the loss and
keep his employees in their jobs
but he's speaking out to warn others i
feel like i have a moral obligation to
as a survivor i have a moral obligation
to
warn other business owners
well so initially about 66 000 of that
roughly 250
000 was recovered by the bank it hadn't
gone out yet but miriam believed the
bank should make up the rest
so he hired a lawyer to negotiate now
they had previously told us they were
not making much progress
but since we reached out to key bank
this week that has changed
the matter has quickly been settled
we're told
and if you've had this happen with key
bank or any others we want to hear from
you
email us at consumer at cbsnews.com
please tell us your story
no anna's very good favorite viewers at
the same time said
do they get the money she goes stay
tuned she did a little shoulder wiggle
stay tuned
and quickly wow i got when she signed
into that that that site looked so real
yeah um but were they actually taking
her information is that what was
happening and the phone call was what
so the scammers are taking the
information and then they take those
credentials and go and use them on the
real site
at the same time that they're talking to
her and getting her stuff right so it's
like a two-handed operation
the phone calls were a stalling tactic
so that you don't go to the real bank
site yes and reach out to your real bank
and call the real bank and say what's
going on with the website at which point
your real bank would say what are you
talking about right
right and you'd say because she hadn't
given any information on the phone
no but she's already logged it all in to
reassure you it's a very sophisticated
what the fbi calls social engineering
techniques it is it is my nightmare when
i get on sites and think about that
especially with a bank
story read the url address very
carefully very carefully
thank you